wie ein fächer führen die straßen von
karlsruhe zu einem zentralen punkt dem
barockschloss von markgraf karl wilhelm
vor 300 jahren ließ er es als seine
residenz errichten
mitten im nirgendwo
zu seiner zeit bauten viele herrscher
neue schlösser der ihre alten in
erbfolgekrieges zerstört wurden so auch
karl wilhelms residenz im namen durlach
vorbild seines neubaus war die
französische architektur tatsächlich
dass man eine flügel anlage eine mehr
flügel anlage ganz im stile des barock
erbaute damals karl wilhelm wollte
offensichtlich diese seitenflügel etwas
abgewinkelt haben und genau in diesem
bereich der dann quasi diesen fächer
bildete entstand dann auch im zuge der
schloss gründung die stadt 1718 zu karl
wilhelm mit seinen mätressen in die neue
residenz seine frau ließ er in durlach
zurück später residierten in karlsruhe
die kurfürsten und großherzöge von baden
heute befindet sich das badische
landesmuseum im schloss zum
stadtgeburtstag ehrt ist den gründer mit
einer ausstellung mit sicherheit ein
mensch der den genuss lebte der
leidenschaften hatte hat ja ganz
abgesehen davon noch einige liebschaften
er war aber auch jemand der gerne
kontrollierte gerne beherrschte aber da
muss man natürlich sagen dass wir auch
ganz im stile der zeit der war ein
absolutistischer landesfest vom barock
ist in karlsruhe nicht viel geblieben
schöne gebäude gibt es trotzdem zum
beispiel die musikhochschule im schloss
gottes
studenten prägen das stadtbild genauso
wie die straßenbahn
bislang denn wie soll zukünftig
unterirdisch fahren
darum wird in karlsruhe viel gebaut und
es wird wohl noch etwas dauern bis die
innenstadt sich wieder in ihrer ganzen
schönheit zeigt auf dem marktplatz steht
das wahrzeichen der stadt die karlsruher
pyramide grabmal des stadtgründers carl
wilhelm
derzeit ist sie komplett verpackt und
nur auf postkarten zu sehen
gleich nebenan das rathaus und die
evangelische stadtkirche
sie wurde anfang des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts nach dem vorbild eines
griechischen tempels gestaltet für
kunstinteressierte hat karlsruhe viel zu
bieten
die staatliche kunsthalle gehört zu den
ältesten museumsbauten deutschlands und
wurde eigens für die sammlung der
badischen markgrafen errichtet hier gibt
es werke aus dem spätmittelalter bis zur
gegenwart zu sehen
für das digitale zeitalter steht das zkm
das zentrum für kunst und
medientechnologie in einer ehemaligen
munitionsfabrik seit 1997 ist es
denkfabrik experimentierraum und museum
zur 300 jahrfeier der stadt hat das zkm
eine große sonderausstellung vorbereitet
schalke ist eine sehr schöne stadt eine
grüne stadt und nur im augenblick ist
eine baustelle
das heißt wir machen eine große
ausstellung im museum selber spielen aus
schwörstadt die stadt
ich sage immer die stadt ist der star
wir haben künstler eingeladen
die spektakuläre groß ist als oder
machen um die baustelle sender zu fuß
machen
das ist eine künstliche wolke einer der
höhepunkte der ausstellung das
kunstprojekt heißt klaus krebs
den sommer über feiert karlsruher
geburtstag dort wo karl wilhelm vor 300
jahren den grundstein für seine residenz
und damit auch für die stadt legen ließ